[Music]
give me the box
[Music]
oh
what is this place the mirror dimension
where i'm in control strange stuff can
we please just talk about this parker
don't you realize that in the multiverse
there are an infinite number of people
who know peter parker is spider-man and
if that spell gets loose they're all
coming here look i know i get it but we
can't just send them home to die it's
their fate
you can't change that any more than you
can change who they are
oh what are you doing
that's right folks spiderman is in fact
peter parker listen i did not kill
mysterio the drones did the drones that
are yours
does any part of you feel relieved about
all this what do you mean
now that everybody knows you don't
really have to hide or lie to people for
the record i never wanted to lie to you
and how do you tell someone that you're
spiderman
now everybody knows
but this isn't about me this is hurting
a lot of people
i've just been thinking about how to fix
all of this
so peter
why do i owe the pleasure i'm sorry to
bother you sir please be safe to have
the universe together i think we're
beyond you calling me sir okay stephen
that feels weird but i'll allow it
when mysterio revealed my identity my
entire life got screwed up
i was wondering if maybe you could make
it so that he never did
strange don't cast that spell
it's too dangerous
fine
i won't
the entire world is about to forget the
peter parker spider-man wait everyone
okay some people still know that's not
how the spell works
so mj's gonna forget about everything
we've ever been through stop tampering
with the spell oh my god ned he's my
best friend my aunt may should really
stop talking
what just happened
we tampered with the stability of space
time
multiverse is a concept about which we
know frighteningly little
the problem is you trying to live two
different lives
the longer you do it the more dangerous
it becomes
[Music]
be careful what you wish for parker
hello peter
[Music]
[Music]